hi there Steve Kaufman here again I just
want to have a I went do a short video
on this whole subject of learning the
basics before I continue with this
series on how I went about learning
these different languages because I
might have created the wrong impression
the basics in a language are important
it is important to speak correctly it's
it is important to focus on key patterns
key phrases
key ways of saying things phrases and
patterns and structures of comma BA all
the time it's just not possible to do it
at the beginning it's much easier to do
it later on for example I find that if I
get a phrase book which has lots of
useful phrases if I try to start with
that I find it very difficult to
concentrate and to remember anything and
I have tried it as when I talk about my
experience of learning Portuguese and
even Russian I did start with phrase
books and I got nowhere I find it's it's
better to start with more or less
meaningful content little short top
dialogues that at least have some kind
of a story to them to get into the
language you get a feel for the language
and and most importantly to build up
your vocabulary build up your words and
do that for awhile without worrying
about any structures sure you can have a
quick review of some of the key issues
in the language you know not spend much
time on it not expect that you're gonna
be able to remember it but then after
about six months or depending on the
language then I find it really useful to
go back to the basics
this can mean you know regular review of
some of the grammar rules which now
start to make sense or what I think is
very useful I wish there was more of
this is sort of concentrated examples of
different patterns in the language so
let's say and I found a book like this
in Russia but I didn't get a CD for it
and it had like 53 patterns and so I'm
reading through the
has a pattern you know if you do
something then something will happen or
whatever it might be
although therefore and so you have all
these patterns and with lots of examples
so no you have enough of a background of
the language that when you hear these
examples you're actually kind of focused
now it has some meaning and I find that
that listening to and reading sort of
concentrations of examples of these
different patterns is helpful and then
you can zero in on these patterns that
that you sometimes notice sometimes
don't notice how difficulty using but
always after you have had sufficient
experience with the language so I'm not
suggesting the basics are not important
I'm only suggesting that you're better
off to go at the basics once you have
had significant exposure to the language
a couple of other comments someone asked
about Chinese characters yeah you have
to learn those and the most frickin
characters up front otherwise you can't
read just like you have to learn the
alphabet of a language if if the
alphabet is different from your own
that's a little different in my mind
from learning key grammar rules or key
you know vocabulary these things you can
go after you know at a later date but
the writing system you got to go out
right away in order to be able to read
whereas to me the phonics is not an
issue because after you've heard a lot
of the language you can then go and
focus in on on you know pronunciation
because personally I don't feel any
great need to produce the language when
I start out so a little bit of a not a
hedge but a further explanation about
the whole issue of basics which are
important but they shouldn't be put like
the cart before the horse they come
afterwards again the old Sufi saying you
can only learn what you already know and
I think it really applies to language
learning thanks